hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
we're going to solve
longest repeating character replacement
and so this is another problem from that
blind 75 list
so we are going to be one step closer to
completing the entire list
the link will be in the description to
this spreadsheet if you do want to take
a look
and hello to the six people that are
currently viewing the
spreadsheet right now you're gonna be in
the next video but okay so let's get
into this problem because it's another
pretty fundamental problem that's really
good to understand so we're given a
string
s and a single integer k and so
basically they tell us that we can
choose
any of the characters in the string and
change it to any other uppercase english
character so in this problem
every character in the input string is
going to be limited to uppercase english
characters and we know that there's 26
uppercase english characters from
capital a to capital z
and so basically we can perform a
replacement on
any of the characters at most k times
so we are allowed to replace k different
characters in the string to any other
character we want
and what we want to do is return the
length of the
longest substring containing the exact
same character we can get after
performing
at most k different replacements
so we just want to return that length we
don't actually have to make those
replacements in the input string
so in this case when we take a look at
the input string we have a
b a b and we're allowed to replace two
of the characters
so what's the longest substring we could
get with the exact same character well
we could replace
one of the b's we could basically
replace both of the b's
with a capital a and then we get four
a's in a row
which would give us an output of four
and we could technically also do the
opposite we could replace the a's
with capital b's and that would give us
the exact same result a length of four
so i'm going to show you how you can
solve this problem in big
o of n time and technically it's going
to be big o of
26 multiplied by n which we know is also
reduces to
big o of n but there's actually
technically an easier
way to do it or at least a more simple
way to do it which is just going to be
a flat big o of n we don't even need
this 26 constant
but this way is actually pretty tricky
to get to
so i'll be going over a little bit of it
but this is kind of the main way that
you'd want to solve this problem
so let's say we're given an input string
like this and we're given a k value now
the most brute force way would just be
check every single substring right
and if we were checking every single sub
string in the entire input array we know
there's n squared sub string so that
wouldn't be the simple
that wouldn't be the most efficient way
to do it but even if we were doing it
like that what exactly are we
looking for if we're looking at a
particular substring
how do we know if this substring is
valid because remember at the end of the
day
we want to maximize the result right the
result is going to be the longest
sub string that contains a single
character and we can make
two replacements so let's look at this
substring alone
how do we know if it's valid well which
character are we going to replace are we
going to want to replace the b's
in order to make it all be amount to
match a or would we want to replace the
a in order to match it with the rest of
the b's
of course we're going to replace the
character that occurs less frequently
right because the number of replacements
we have is
limited so we would want to replace the
character
that the characters that are less
frequent so in other words
we want all characters in a particular
window to
match the most common character
in that window so what we're going to be
doing is we are going to have a
hash map or a array which is going to
take
every single character in this case we
only have characters a and b
and we're going to count the number of
occurrences of each character
so for example if we were looking at
this substring we see that there's three
b's and we have a single
a so how do we know if this window is
valid what we're gonna do is we're gonna
take
the length of the window which is gonna
be four
right we're gonna take the length of the
window right which we know in this case
is four
and we're gonna take the length or the
count of the most frequent character in
this case
we know that that's b and the count of
it happens to be
three so we're gonna take four minus
three and
from that we're gonna get a one now what
does this value one tell us
it tells us the number of characters in
our window right
now that we need to replace in order to
make it
match the most frequent character b
right we have a b here
we want everything to match a b in this
case we only have an a right but it
could be possible like
who knows maybe that we would have a c
over here right or an x
over here and it doesn't really matter
what the characters
are we just know that b is the most
frequent character in the window
and the other characters that are not b
a and z
for example are the characters we want
to replace so we can calculate the
number of characters we want to pull
that we want to replace just like this
and so so we want to replace one
character how do we know if we have
enough
replacements to do one character well of
course that's our input parameter
k right so what we're confirming here is
that
this value is less than or equal to
k as long as this condition is true
that means our current window is valid
that means we have enough replacements
to make those replacements
in our current window so this is the
main condition that we're going to be
checking the other question is how are
we going to know which character is the
most frequent well
the brute force way is gonna be taking a
look at our map
of counts and we know that the max size
of this could possibly be
26 because we'd only have 26 different
characters
so doing finding the max character is
going to be big o of 26 so that's
a little bit more inefficient than we
would like but it's technically still
linear time like the overall algorithm
is still going to be linear time
the the last thing that we're gonna have
to do though is to this
uh equation we're gonna have to add a
sliding window technique so basically
what we're gonna do is we're gonna take
our window
start at the beginning expand it as much
as we can as long as the
the condition that we mentioned is valid
if the condition is not valid then we're
going to take our left pointer
and then take our left pointer and then
shift it as well
until the string becomes valid once
again
so we're going to have a left and right
pointer so initially left is gonna be at
the beginning and
right is also gonna be at the beginning
and also the counts of a
and b are initially gonna be zero now
we're gonna look at the first character
right
that's where our right pointer happens
to be we're gonna look at it we're gonna
say okay we have a
we have a single a right we're going to
take our count of a
and set it to 1 now so is this
window valid as in can this window be
the exact same character
with within two replacements of course
it can right that's kind of the trivial
case but
we would still calculate it and the way
we would calculate it is get the size of
our window right now we can see the size
of our window is
one subtracted by the count of
the most frequent character in this case
we know the most frequent character is a
one minus one
is that greater is that less than or
equal to k we know k is two so of course
uh this is going to equal zero zero is
less than equal to two which is k
right so of course this window is valid
that's kind of a trivial case
next we're going to shift our right
pointer to the next character right
so now we have a b so we're going to
increment the count of b in our map
so b is now going to be set to 1. in
this case the length of our window is 2
the most frequent character is either of
these right and the
the count of that frequent character is
gonna be one so we're gonna have two
minus one equal to one
so this is the number of replacements
that we would have to do and
looking at our current window that makes
sense right we'd have to replace at
least one of these two characters
so we're going to ensure that this the
number of replacements that we need to
do is less than or equal to k which is
two of course that's true so
our window is currently valid i guess i
did forget to
update our result so since this window
is valid the length of the window is
gonna be
set to the result right so right now the
result is two two is the length of the
longest window that we can get
so that's our result for now so now
let's continue next we're gonna shift
our right pointer to the third character
so now
we get another a so we're gonna take the
count of a
and increment it all the way to two and
we're basically going to repeat our
algorithm so once again we're gonna get
the length of the window three minus the
count of the most frequent character we
see the most frequent character is
a so the count of is two three minus two
is one
is that less than or equal to two which
is k yes of course it is so
this window is also valid we can update
our result now to three so we found
another window even longer so i'm going
to take
our right pointer once again and then
shift it over to the b
so now we're going to be since we
reached another b we're going to
increment the count of b
to 2 now and so the length of our window
now is 4
and the count of the most frequent
character is either of these and that's
going to be 2
4 minus 2 is equal to 2. is that less
than or equal to k
k is 2 in this case so of course once
again this condition does hold so
once again we found a window that's
longer than our result we found a window
now of length
four and so once again we're going to
take our right pointer and shift it so
now
another b let's increment the count of b
to three so the length of the window now
is five
minus the count of the most frequent
character charac that character is b
five minus three is this two in that and
less than or equal to k
of course it's still true because when
you look at our window
we have three b's so that means we're
going to be replacing the a's
so we're gonna need to make two
replacements and we are allowed to make
two replacements
okay so now we're finally gonna get to
the case that i mentioned earlier where
we're gonna have to take our left
pointer and then slide it to the right
which is why this is a sliding window
problem so now we reached an
a so we're gonna take the count of a and
set it to three so now we have a
count three and b count three so let's
take the size of our window six
subtract from it the count of the most
frequent character it's gonna be
either of these so six minus three means
we need to make three replacements
is that less than or equal to k k is two
so we exceeded k right we exceeded the
number of replacements we're allowed to
make
if we wanted this window to be valid we
have to replace three characters in it
but we're not allowed to do that so what
we have to do
is shrink the size of our window until
we
are valid so we're going to take our
left pointer and
shift it to the right so now the left
pointer is going to be over here it's
going to be at the b
so since we removed this a from our
window
we have to decrement the count of a in
our window so i'm going to cross this
three out and now it's
actually going to be set to 2. i kind of
ran out of room but i hope this is still
readable
so now the count of a is two so now
let's once again
check is our window valid well the size
of the window now is
five and the count of the most frequent
character is
b and that's gonna be three so five
minus three is gonna be equal to two
is that less than or equal to k yes we
are once again
valid so this is technically a valid
window and i think i forgot to update
the result earlier when we had a window
of size five so
the result right now would be size five
because the longest window we can make
is either this window or the window that
we had
uh earlier with you know these first
five characters
but yeah and so at this point we would
stop our algorithm because we did find a
window of
5 that is valid and our right pointer
cannot be shifted
anymore so this is the general algorithm
so it's a basic sliding it's a
fundamental sliding window problem with
this particular condition
being important but there's actually one
way you can do it without
having to look through the entire
hashmap
every time you want to find the most
frequent character
that occurs and it's kind of tricky
to arrive at the solution but it's
pretty easy to implement once you can
figure it out
i'll explain the algorithm at a high
level i don't want to waste too much
time on it but basically we're going to
be having another variable
and it's going to be called max
frequency basically the count of the
most frequent character at any given
time
so basically you know for example if we
had a as
a count of three and b is count two we'd
say okay the count of the mo
the most frequent character occurs three
times so max f is going to be three
and so any time you know if we got a b
we inc
let's say we incremented our b all the
way up to four then we want to update
our max frequency to four right so we'd
always want this to be the most frequent
character
now the one problem is if we're trying
to maintain the count of the most
frequent character
what happens when we take our left
pointer for example right and then
shift it right when we do that we're
basically removing a character
and therefore we're gonna have to update
our count map right we are gonna do that
but and if that does happen right let's
say we took b and then
from four we decremented it all the way
down to
two for example then we have to rescan
this entire map
and then find okay what's now what's the
new most frequent character right so
we'd have to take our max frequency
and from four downgrade it all the way
to
a three for example so then we'd have to
set it to a three
but and that would basically defeat the
purpose right we'd still have to do that
big o of 26 calculation to scan through
this
but it's technically true that you
don't have to decrement this max
frequency
but the main idea is this the result
is only going to be maximized as we find
a
new max frequency right because remember
what we were doing we were taking the
length of the window
subtracted by the max frequency right
whatever the most occurring character
was and we wanted to minimize this right
so basically we want the
length we want the length to be
maximized because that's what our result
is going to be set to
so therefore we also want the max
frequency to be maximized because we
want to ensure
that this is less than or equal to
k and k is going to be a constant
so for example let's say i had a max
frequency of four
but let's say now the new max frequency
got downgraded to a three i'm
still gonna leave this as a four because
it's not going to
change our result because for example if
i had a
6 minus 4 that was that was less than or
equal to k which is 2 in our example
and if i leave this as a 4 i'm basically
overestimating what the max frequency is
but we know at least at
one given point in time it was a four so
therefore we were able to take the
length
six and then set it equal to our result
and now
if we're ever so let's say our result is
now six if we're
ever going to increase the result from 6
to another
number like for example 7 we would
require
our max frequency to increase if it
stays the same
or if it decreases our result is never
going to change because we only change
our result
when we increase our max frequency
because that's the only way
this condition here is going to be true
so
if our max frequency is downgraded we
don't have to actually update it we
don't have to look through the entire
hash map to find the new max
frequency but if we increase our max
frequency for example if i took this
a and then from three i set it equal to
a five
then that's that's something we can
check and big o of
one time and then if we increase this
then we definitely
do want to update our max frequency and
increase it and that's something we can
do in big o of one time so
i know i probably went a little too long
into this but the main idea here
i'm trying to get at is the easy way to
solve this problem with a sliding window
is going to be big o
of 26 times n which is technically
linear but there is a
clever way to do this in big o of end
time that honestly i didn't figure out
on my own and i wouldn't really expect
other people to be able to figure it out
on their own like in an interview at all
but i will show this the standard
solution and i'll also show the code for
this more optimized solution
okay so now let's jump into the code and
the code is actually a lot easier than
the visual example that i gave a lot
shorter for sure so we're gonna have a
hash map to count the occurrences
of each character and we're also gonna
have a result which is going to tell us
the longest
substring that we can create with k
replacements and we're going to have a
left pointer which is going to be at 0
and then our right pointer is going to
go through every single position
in the entire string s so what we're
going to do
is for the character at position r we're
going to increment the count of it
we're going to take 1 plus whatever the
count currently was
count dot get this character and if the
character doesn't exist in our hash map
we're just going to return a default
value of zero that's what this function
is doing
and so before what we're going to
obviously do is update our result right
and we want to set the result equal to
the max that it's ever been
and set it basically equal to the size
of the window we can get the size of the
window
so we're going to take the max of result
and the size of the window the size of
the window can be gotten with
right minus left plus one and
but before we do this before we update
the result we want to make sure that the
current window is
valid so what i'm going to do is
basically say while and i don't think
you'd actually need a while here you
could just do if but i'm just going to
do while just
because so while the window is not valid
and we would know that by taking the
length of the window which we have down
here so i'm just going to copy and paste
that the length of the window
subtracted by the most the count of the
most frequent character which can be
gotten with max
of count dot values
right we're basically going through the
hash map which could be size 26 and just
getting the max value from it
so this is the number of replacements
that we have to do and if the number of
replacements was
greater than the number of replacements
that's allowed which is equal to k
that's when we would want to shift our
left pointer so we'd want to increment
our left pointer
but before we increment the left pointer
we'd want to take the count of the
character
at the left position and then decrement
it
by one and that is the entire algorithm
after all of that is done after we've
gone through the entire string then we
can just simply return our result
and as you can see this is pretty
efficient it's linear time it's about
as efficient as you would need i think
but i'm going to make that slight
optimization that i showed you i'm going
to maintain the max frequency in a
single variable
so that we won't have to do this
operation where we're getting the max of
the entire
hash map instead up here before we
execute that loop i'm going to say max
frequency is going to be equal
to the max of what it currently is max
frequency or
it's equal to the frequency of the
character that we just added a value to
maybe that character became the most
frequent character
so we would have to update our max
frequency and we can do that
just like this and this is a constant
time operation we're not scanning any
list or anything
and then once we have this max frequency
we can use it in
this loop execution right so we can
replace this
and just use max f for that and the
thing is
notice how even when we're shifting left
we're incrementing the left pointer
we're potentially removing characters
from our window we're still not
decrementing max f because we actually
don't need to
it won't end up affecting the result if
we for if we just don't decrement it
and that very slight optimization which
is really simple
in terms of code but it's kind of hard
to see why we're allowed to do that
watch how much more efficient it makes
our algorithm
so as you can see look it definitely
improved it i think it was
50 milliseconds different so this is
significantly faster
it's hard to see why though i would
definitely
not expect most people to be able to
figure that out
so i hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching